[Aplausos]
como estamos
qué gusto que estén aquí con nosotros
antes de expal me estás me da muchísimo
gusto estar aquí en este círculo rojo
estar con ustedes es un placer
[Música]
mi objetivo de estar aquí y de mi
transformación
es porque me sentía en deuda con la
audiencia
durante 22 años la red y forme edite
todo tipo de noticias que tenían que ver
con tragedia humana con el lado más
obscuro
actos terroristas guerras decapitaciones
torturas
crimen organizado narcotráfico todos los
días tenía que salir a dar la cara y
pues estar informando de las muertes de
la lucha del crimen organizado del ex
presidente felipe calderón
durante 22 años estuve dando las
noticias más terribles tenía que ver las
imágenes que a veces ni siquiera podían
salir al aire porque eran obscenas y
demasiado violentas
la consigna de mis jefes era muy
sencilla si tu historia no tiene sangre
simplemente no sale al aire
tenemos que dar sangre para el
sacrificio del dios rating
y me decían mis jefes
a mayor violencia mayor audiencia
sin embargo pensé que era un trabajo
digno era un trabajo digno que me dio
para mantener a mi hijo como madre
soltera pero poco a poco mis amigos me
veían y me veían transformarme y se
reían de mí cuando les decía que me
vieran en la televisión me decían
veronica mi televisión está sangrando
con el programa que estoy viendo le está
saliendo sangre a la pantalla y
empezaron a burlar de mí pero la que
empezó a sangrar fui yo empecé a sangrar
con enfermedades con tumores benignos
con
pérdida de entidad me pasaron todo tipo
de cosas mis miedos y mis culpas por dar
mensajes negativos empezaron a hacer que
yo fabricará eventos el miedo y la
gratitud son un imán y mi miedo hizo
atraer un evento de un intento de
secuestro en acapulco
soy consciente hoy de que yo a traje ese
evento
empecé a rezar el padrenuestro y de
repente una voz me empezó a hablar y me
decía izquierda derecha derecha
izquierda y perdí a estos presuntos
secuestradores cuando llegaron los
policías ministeriales me dijeron
esto fue un intento de secuestro ese es
el modus operandi y bueno para no ser el
cuento largo empecé yo a sangrar
emocionalmente y tuve que vivir una
transformación interna
durante 22 años como periodistas tenemos
que estar señalando
y denunciando todo lo que está mal esa
es nuestra labor hacer visible al
invisible pero me cansé y dije ya me
cansé de dar malas noticias
ahora quiero dar el trapito para limpiar
lo que está sucio ya señale mucho lo que
está sucio te puedo dar a cambio y bueno
ahí comenzó mi transformación
se puede decir que salir del closet
salir del closet porque a veces si tú no
te mueves del lugar y tú no te sacas de
tu zona de confort la vida te saca a
golpes eso ténganlo por seguro llega el
terremoto del 19 de septiembre yo estaba
desempleada y de repente una revista me
sacó una portada
veronica es chamán a veronica es vidente
imagínense una periodista seria como yo
que de repente se dedica pues a su parte
privada que su parte espiritual es tu
vida privada
desde el 2014 empecé con este turismo
espiritual que yo le llamo para tratar
de salvar mi matrimonio
tomé dos maestrías de reiki
estudié theta healing una técnica de
sanación que utiliza la onda cerebral
theta es una onda cerebral que te lleva
a un estado de meditación muy profundo
donde puedes empezar a crear y a cambiar
creencias hoy estamos aquí para cambiar
creencias para transformar muros pero
con todo esto que aprendí empecé una
transformación interna y bueno lo que
les quiero decir es que así como las
ostras agarran la basura y la
transforman en una perla
yo eso hice y hoy vengo a compartir con
ustedes esas perlas
y esa basura me dio depresión post-parto
fui parte del 20% de las mujeres que nos
da esa enfermedad por cuestiones
hormonales y multifactoriales pero de
repente me di cuenta que mi divorcio fue
producto de la depresión post-parto
nunca quise tomar un antidepresivo nunca
he tomado un antidepresivo mi ignorancia
me hacía creer que si tomaba un
antidepresivo no podría lactar y podría
contaminar a mi bebé no a veces somos
muy ignorantes y no nos dejamos guiar
por los médicos pero
eso derivó en una en un evento muy muy
doloroso es lo más doloroso que he
pasado el divorcio después de eso pues
tuve soledad pérdida de identidad en fin
a lo que voy es que no sé si alguien de
aquí levante la mano ha sentido un
ataque de pánico una crisis de ansiedad
gracias gracias por la honestidad
gracias
sentí todo eso también me pusieron el
cuerno un exnovio y fidelidad le suena y
eso también
resuena
bueno el caso es que todo eso me hizo de
repente darme cuenta que todo ese dolor
toda esa angustia podía servir si yo la
compartía con otro ser humano
esa basura la convertía en perlas
y el mensaje que hoy vengo a darles
es este
todos tenemos el don de sanación todos
todos
el cuerpo humano está capacitado para
transformar
tener salud bienestar y equilibrio
yo te pregunto tú qué estás haciendo
para transformar tu basura en perlas
miren somos vibración
somos vibración y aunque veamos materia
aunque toquemos una mesa una silla es
vibración las moléculas los átomos son
vibración entonces imagínense ustedes el
impacto que tiene sobre la materia sobre
todo lo que podamos ver mis creencias
mis emociones y mis pensamientos y no lo
dije yo lo han dicho muchos doctores
como el doctor yo dispensa como el
doctor ali hamza tal y
el doctor en moto hizo maravillosos
experimentos con el agua coge los
moléculas del agua y se dio cuenta que
los pensamientos las palabras las
creencias influyan en la estructura
molecular se dio cuenta que en estas
células les ponía un papelito a una le
puso amor a otra le puso odio esa célula
perdón esa molécula que está ahí es de
amor entonces se dio cuenta y comprobó
que nuestros pensamientos pueden alterar
imagínense ustedes si somos 70% de agua
en nuestro cuerpo aproximadamente en el
planeta tierra somos 70% agua lo que es
afuera es adentro lo que hay un
macrocosmos lo hay en un microcosmos
entonces imagínense lo que puede hacer
nuestras creencias palabras y emociones
sobre todo
tenemos ahí un campo muy abierto para la
transformación
bueno después me dediqué a estudiar
theta healing como les comentaba
y un tanatólogo me acerco con niños con
cáncer y con mujeres con cáncer y una
plática en el estado de mexico a mujeres
con cáncer de mama el instituto mexicano
del seguro social me nombró embajadora
contra la lucha de cáncer y luego este
doctor también me llevó con niños con
cáncer en la ciudad de mexico
estábamos dando terapias gratis un grupo
de terapeutas
para víctimas del terremoto les digo yo
estaba desempleada y dije pero ahorita
no puedo donar dinero que voy a adorar
dado a donar estoy preocupada porque
además yo estaba en los ángeles cuando
empezó a temblar entonces me daba
impotencia no poder ayudar a mi país
estando tan lejos y me di cuenta que
cuando no tenemos nada que dar tenemos
mucho que dar
en los momentos más difíciles podemos
dar no tienes dinero puedes dar tiempo
puedes dar conocimientos puedes dar
acompañamiento a quien más lo necesita
trabajé con estos niños y este es el
milagro de betito corre vídeo por favor
pero gracias por la terapia soy apetito
yo ya me duro
ellos
bueno betito estaba de cabeza
apetito es un niño maravilloso no juzgan
los niños viven en el presente los niños
son maravillosos tenemos que tener mente
de niños pero a lo que voy con esto es
que yo entré en pánico cuando me dijo el
doctor vas a hablar con estos niños yo
hay un doctor pero es que sí he tenido
pacientes de cáncer pero nunca niños o
sea no se van a concentrar no van a
poder meditar
san diego empezó a intervenir entre la
terapia y el niño no el ego siempre
quiere tener resultados inmediatos y
maravillosos y el ego compara en fin el
caso es que el vídeo de betito fue un
regalo que me dio la vida a los 15 días
el médico me manda este vídeo y me dice
verónica le hicimos estudios a betito y
el niño pues ya no está desahuciado el
niño ya está fuera de la zona de peligro
y yo no no no a ver tienes que repetir
los estudios debe de haber una confusión
no el niño está bien está funcionando la
mezcla que estás haciendo estoy yo
mezclando lo que es teta healing un
curso de milagros
y también rey que es lo que yo estoy
usando y estas son las disciplinas las
ramas de la ciencia y las terapias de
sanación que están revolucionando el
mundo de la transformación
siempre creemos que algo es blanco o
negro y en medio hay una gama enorme de
grises esta es la grama la epigenética
está yendo más allá de los genes de
verdad créanme se puede cambiar el adn
se puede transformar el adn por nuestras
actitudes nuestros comportamientos
nuestras creencias y nuestras emociones
y bueno lo que hice competido y con
estas mujeres es transformar las células
programar sus células les hable a las
células y les dije células cancerígenas
mueran sé
por ahí alguien me dijo que al cáncer le
llaman las células eternas porque nunca
mueren se reproducen y se reproducen
entonces lo que hice fue programar estas
células para que murieran y las células
sanas las programe para que siguieran
reproduciéndose eso fue lo que hice
tanto con las mujeres con cáncer de mama
como con los niños a las mujeres como ya
son adultos les cambié las creencias
para que liberaran resentimientos y
perdonará eso es básicamente lo que hice
con ellos pero de verdad tenemos que
tener mente y corazón abiertos para
conocer este tipo de técnicas y de
disciplinas que de verdad están
revolucionando
la mayoría de los pacientes que ha
atendido tienen creencias básicas miren
una creencia que es bien importante es
no merezco no soy suficientemente bueno
no me quieren no a veces el inconsciente
es el que nos rige
si tú crees algo
y tu boca dice algo quizás estés
mintiendo pero el inconsciente nunca
miente por eso usamos a veces el péndulo
donde para adelante tu cuerpo dice así
hacia atrás dice no entonces hay muchas
técnicas donde podemos ir directamente
al inconsciente y desde ahí hacer el
cambio de creencias
decía por ahí creo que carl jung que
decía si no cambias y sanas tu
inconsciente le seguirá llamando destino
no estamos destinados a estar enfermos
no existen de hecho las enfermedades
solamente existen los enfermos
y muchos tenemos enfermedades
emocionales que ni siquiera nos damos
cuenta del simple hecho de vivir en una
ciudad te hacen neurótico
esta es la entrevista que más me ha
gustado en mi carrera he entrevistado
muchísimas personas imagínense a lo
largo de 22 años como conductora titular
de varios noticieros pero aparte como
corresponsal nick voy allí
es el australiano sin extremidades
asignación que a los 88 años de vida ni
que le sean tanto bullying que él
intentó suicidarse
se trató de ahogar en la tina en la
bañera de su casa he tenido la bendición
de entrevistarlo dos veces para dos
cadenas de televisión el abrazo más
increíble que he recibido es de este
hombre sin brazos
el poco fondo trató de suicidarse dos
veces y después se acercó muchísimo
adiós me impactó muchísimo su fe él
tiene una palabra que una frase que dice
fe en acción face in action
y de verdad tenemos que poner atención
en esto porque el suicidio en aumento
está en jóvenes va en aumento en
personas adultas en méxico y en todo el
mundo hace aproximadamente dos meses
tres famosos se quitaron la vida en una
misma semana la hermana de la reina
máxima de holanda
también la gran diseñadora kate spade y
el chef deciden anthony bourdain
tres personas que todos diríamos bueno
yo quiero su vida
yo quiero su dinero yo quiero su
aristocracia y que creen tenían tres
cosas en común
llevaban una vida de excesos
kate spade tengo entendido era adicta al
celular
no sabían qué hacer con sus vacíos
existenciales vivían en una profunda
depresión y tenían un dolor emocional
enorme algo estamos haciendo mal como
sociedad que no entendemos el verdadero
significado de felicidad
y de éxito
tenemos que poner atención
porque el suicidio es algo antinatural
es algo que no debe suceder y ya varios
de mis ponentes de mis compañeros
anteriores hablaron del suicidio y este
es un tema realmente urgente entonces
que necesitamos yo con depresión
posparto no tome antidepresivos el emple
pegue al spinning le pegue al reiki le
pegue al dt healing buscaba métodos
alternativos o complementarios claro
cuando un depresivo necesita necesita
tomarlos tiene que tomar los no hay que
hacerle caso a los médicos no hay que
comprar
un diagnóstico médico mi papá le
detectaron cáncer de próstata y él nunca
creyó en el diagnóstico y al poco tiempo
ya estaba como si nada todo está en la
mente hay también por ahí experimentos
del doctor yo dispensa donde te dice el
placebo eres tú y te dice que hay
personas que empiezan a morir pero por
la mente
por ejemplo la segunda guerra mundial se
les acabó la morfina y les empezaron a
inyectar
agua salina y de repente ya no sentían
dolor y seguían los soldados dos heridos
los operaban y todo y sin anestesia y
todo porque les hacían creer ese es el
poder de la mente ese es el poder de la
mente que hoy vengo a invitarte que
ejerzas porque no la estamos usando a
veces more meditations les medication
necesitamos más meditación y menos
medicación
y bueno mis contenidos en televisión
desde hace un tiempo para acá se han
dedicado a promover contenidos de
prevención de adicciones prevención del
delito y cultura de la paz
por eso fundé los huevos no son al gusto
ese es mi podcast hay 60 programas ahí
para que los vean desde el punto de
vista comercial fue un fracaso
no he logrado hasta ahorita recuperar un
solo centavo de esa inversión pero que
creen 3 jovencitas se nos acercaron y
nos dijeron cambió de opinión me quería
quitar la vida y gracias a que escuche
este espacio o estas entrevistas pues ya
estoy aquí y estoy tratando de hacer una
vida diferente y bueno por último les
quiero comentar que el perdón
corrige todo conflicto ya sea de salud
financiero laboral de cualquier tipo el
perdón me perdono lo perdono me perdono
por haber tenido esta actitud me perdono
por haber tenido este comportamiento me
perdono por haber tenido esta creencia
falsa esta alianza con mis antepasados
como en las constelaciones familiares
y finalmente todas las emociones
creencias negativas vienen del miedo y
todas las positivas vienen del amor no
hay más elijes miedo o eliges amor
y bueno hoy vengo a decirte
que recuperes y primero que te creas
que eres un hijo amado de dios creas o
no que ascendió sea escéptico o no seas
escéptico tienes una vida espiritual y
ojo no estoy hablando de religiones
tienes el poder
de transformar tu realidad eres un
agente de cambio
así se llama mi libro tú
eres un milagro y tengo ahí dos
capítulos uno donde dice que las
enfermedades
son una ilusión
porque atrás de toda enfermedad hay una
emoción estancada una emoción reprimida
hay culpas cuando yo empecé a trabajar
mis culpas deje de enfermarme
me perdone por el divorcio me perdone
por llevarme a mi hijo vive eeuu y
alejarlo de su papá de sus abuelos en
fin pero la depresión post-parto y
cualquier depresión de verdad viene de
un profundo egoísmo yo no conozco una
sola persona
que esté practicando el servicio que sea
altruista que esté haciendo una labor
social y que esté deprimida pongas a
pensar en eso no se puede o piensas en
ti o piensas en el otro y cuando piensas
en el otro y te dedicas a servir tus
problemas se hacen de este tamaño así es
de que hoy vengo a pasarles ese mensaje
que todos podemos sanar que la
transformación empieza de adentro hacia
afuera porque nadie puede dar lo que no
tiene y mientras más retrases tu cambio
tu transformación
el agarrar el cincel y empezar cada día
a tirar tus muros para cambiar hacia la
luz
pues más te va a doler porque lo que
resistes persiste te pido por favor que
hoy descubras tu naturaleza sobrenatural
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]